what would you do stardate four to six
95.3
was a pretty big day for me I was given
my first command but it turned out to be
more difficult than I'd planned so I
would do records and what if I fail what
if I freeze up with the Borg on our tail
one if the choice I make is wrong and
Recker said to me Wesley gave me a break
it's arrogant if you'll never make a
mistake
but when you're in that position we have
to ask yourself one question
Oh one word Captain Picard - oh but
would captain the guard dude
he'd ensure the safety of a ship and his
crew
and then complete the mission and make
himself a better version bring peace to
the galaxy and do it for free oh yeah
that's what gotten the guard to do
oh yeah it's gotten the guard with you
I just woke up after three centuries and
my first song was of money not that my
family was gone but the spa guy in a
jumpsuit said to me that they'd polished
ger and see everything I'd worked for
was gone yet there was nothing to
withdraw I tended him with the invest in
if you don't have me corporations he
said we'd best in ourselves and maybe I
should try that over myself because
that's what captain to guard do
yeah that's what captain the guard would
do he didn't sure the safety of his ship
and his crew and then complete the
mission and make himself a better person
bring peace to the galaxy and he do it
for free
oh yeah let's got the guard - oh yeah -
gotten the garden dude remember when he
told us to remove the saucer section
even though we were at warp nine there
was no objection and yeah we could have
killed the board using you but we agreed
with the captain it was the wrong thing
to do and I'd rather follow Dixon hill
private detective then observe Saum
outmoded an obscure prime directive a
that after he was tortured for 40 days
and nights he told that Cardassian that
there were still four lights and yeah
when you're confused and the choice is
too hard just think Captain Picard just
think of Captain Picard
what would Captain Picard
do
yeah what would Captain Picard - he
saved the galaxy and he do it for free
he'd protect the whole world and he'd
still get the girl and he saved the
Federation and her
Klingons admiration oh yeah
took out the card we do
oh yeah that's what can the guard would
do